[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the columnist and broadcaster steve
richards and the telegraph deputy
political editor lucy fisher so let's
see what's on some of those front pages
for you now
you're just so fuelish the metro leads
with transport secretary grant schatz
blaming the fuel supply crisis on
truckers and drivers for panic buying
shambles is how the mirror describes the
chaos at petrol stations
while the sun warns of a panic monday as
drivers trade punches in the queue for
fuel
the star claims some petrol stations
have hiked prices as motorists chew
outside
boris johnson is set to meet ministers
tomorrow to decide on whether to call in
the army to tackle the crisis that's on
the front of the guardian
and that's also the lead story in the
times which reports the move is likely
the telegraph has the same story
as we wait for the full results of the
german elections the frankfurter alga
miner has this headline spd and cdu
claim leadership schultz and lachette
want to form a government
the mail reports on technical issues on
a smart motorways claiming one in ten
vital safety cameras aren't working
and the financial times understands the
government intends to lower the salary
threshold at which graduates start
paying back student loans
so with me tonight steve richards and
lucy fisher welcome to you both good
evening let's start with the times and
uh the story there that the army is to
be called in to help
the government tackle the the fuel
crisis uh let's hear from you first of
all steve
well it's uh
you know if in doubt send for the army
there are clear lines of command and
control with the army but it seems to me
that all these measures that we've heard
over the last 24 hours including the
u-turn over uh visas for 5 000 drivers
none of them
addressed the scale of the challenge
which is a shortage of around 130 000
drivers is it something 100 000 or
whatever
arising from a number of issues
including brexit and the shortage of
east europeans who are here and it's
applying to many sectors um so this
might help with the sort of short term
but when people sort of accuse and there
are headlines about it which we're
coming to you know panic buying and all
the rest of it where you can sort of
understand the reason why people
are panicking i know there's enough fuel
around but if there aren't drivers to
deliver it they're not going to get to
the petrol stations and um it seems to
me that this is going to run for quite
some time it's not a short-term issue
that's going to be solved by the army
yes and it's it's very easy to tell
people to to not panic but when the the
figures tell us that up to 90 of petrol
stations have run dry um that is
worrying
well that's right it is rather a futile
uh warning that we've heard from grant
chaps the transport secretary and others
clearly it's fallen on deaf ears today
we've heard reports of fights at petrol
stations as desperate
motorists
barge each other trying to get the last
of the petrol at the pumps
5
500 petrol stations out of britain's 8
000
may have run out of petrol according to
the upper estimates put forward by
industry bodies some four courts have
put a ban on people buying any more than
30 pounds worth of petrol at once so
it's been another day of scenes and
i think the transport secretaries
broadcast round on sky
and other media organizations this
morning perhaps didn't strike quite the
wisest tone he um sought to apportion
blame to the railroad haulers
association suggesting that leaks from a
private government meeting
warnings from bp had precipitated the
panic buying rather than perhaps taking
ownership of some of the longer term
problems with the hgv driver crisis
which has been coming down the line for
some time now
um we look at the guardian and in in the
detail of their story um they're saying
that this operation called operation
escalin it was conceived years ago
during the planning for a no deal brexit
and would involve the drafting of
hundreds of soldiers to drive a reserve
fleet of 80 tankers so it seems as if
it's something that that has been
planned for although we don't seem to be
in a situation um that suggests it's
been planned for at all steve
well
the no deal brexit uh boris johnson said
britain was going to flourish in such a
context but clearly there were plans for
a crisis on the scale that we're now
experiencing
the the issue again it seems to me is
that yeah great that 80
vessels will be driven around presumably
targeting different areas um but the
scale of this is is much bigger and to
be honest i had quite a long journey
yesterday i went to a petrol station and
the woman who served me was hilarious
said everyone's right it's wrong to
panic a right to panic she that station
was about to run out
with long queues
because if you get the sense of shortage
what are you going to do if you're
dependent on a car as many people are
for work and all the rest of it so you
can see how
it feeds on itself and as i say it
doesn't seem to me that any of the
measures announced so far address the
scale of the thing and it was predicted
it was predicted during the brexit
referendum that there would be shortages
on this scale
and as you suggest the government was
preparing for something like this in the
event of a no deal
but given the nature of boris johnson's
brexit deal
there was always going to be this issue
anyway
we're out of all the deals that used to
encourage people to come here
and it's great as ministers are saying
that wages are going up but that will
not tackle the short-term issue of
demand and supply
lucy what about the the tactic of the
the competition act being temporarily
relaxed to allow
oil companies to target petrol stations
running low on fuel in the short term is
that the best
road forward
well it feels like one small cog in in
the the greater uh plan or at least the
of what's needed here one piece of that
puzzle and clearly it makes sense in
this short term acute phase of the
crisis and to allow companies to share
information to share resources uh
perhaps if there are vehicles going to
the same region or local area and to
work together but i think as steve has
made clear there doesn't appear so far
to be a sustainable long-term plan here
when you look at the government's move
in recent days the u-turn to
allow
visas for foreign htv truck drivers up
to 5000 before christmas well that's
only a drop in the ocean of how many are
needed there's also a lot of concern
that in fact there's an http hgv driver
shortage across europe so it's not even
clear that there will be people from the
continent wanting to come to britain to
do this
and at the moment of course all the
focus is on fuel there are also concerns
about other um sectors particularly
supermarkets um that are seeing
increasing shortages i think as the
winter continues uh we'll see this
crisis bite potentially further
particularly in the run-up to christmas
with people looking to get the products
parents especially wanting the toys uh
and latest gadgets for their children
this could spell a lot of political
problems for the conservatives
the mirror their headline shambles and
again they're they're suggesting that
the prime minister knew about this
impending crisis he was warned about it
back in in june but but did nothing um
and their piece is saying that this
could last for at least another 10 days
yeah
i'm sorry sorry steve go ahead steve go
ahead
well just very quickly yeah 10 days
minimum it seems to me um because
you know there are longer term
implications here and there are patterns
of
boris johnson being warned about
possible
uh eruptions or crises and and not
acting when there was some sort of
time to do so um and so uh yeah i mean i
think that this will
be a problem for uh ten days seems to me
the best we can hope for but let's hope
it isn't more than that
lucy come in
i think well i think c is right and when
we're looking at the plans that are
being put forward in the papers today
that the government is said to be
considering
hundreds of soldiers could be scrambled
to be involved in driving this reserve
fleet of 80 tankers but it's thought
that many of them may already be on
deployments so that will take up to
several weeks to implement that plan as
those um soldiers are clawed back from
whatever they're doing at the moment
again with the visa
solution it could be up to several weeks
until those visas
are successfully handed out to to
foreign drivers so again in the very
short term some of the measures
announced won't take effect immediately
and it's also the case that it's a very
lofty invitation to these drivers you
know come over we'll give you a visa but
we were kicking you out again on
christmas eve i mean i wonder how many
are going to take up this uh invitation
have a look now at the financial times
and their coverage of the german
elections it is incredibly close much
closer than many were predicting lucy um
are you surprised by that
well in a sense no it's been a very
unpredictable election up to a third of
voters uh said that they were unsure
going into the polls we've seen the
polls switch both ways uh in the months
leading up to this ballot we saw at the
beginning merkel's christian democrat
party in the lead at one point the green
party was in the lead and then of course
there was the late surge for the social
democrats according to two exit polls
tonight it looks like the social
democrats may have just edged it to be
the largest party with predictions
they've got between 25 to 26 of the vote
but that's only one percentage point
ahead of the christian democrats on 24
to 25 percent of course we need to wait
till the votes are counted but uh it's
all looking on a knife edge very
exciting and lots of talk of a three-way
coalition which could potentially take
months to flesh out yeah it's very very
close to call unusual for german
politics steve
yeah and it's so different to our own
isn't it it's interesting that um we are
now going to see in germany this sort of
negotiation possibly lasting as lucy
suggests for a long time
before a new government is formed with
our system where in theory you have two
parties with very broad coalitions
between
within each of the two parties and one
tends to win but in our system sort of
breaking down now that they're not so
much broad coalitions with leaders
feeling obliged to take on one wing or
another
whereas in germany now you have
something way a more transparent process
where different parties stand
and on the basis of the votes then
negotiate a partnership rather than
our system here where two theoretical
broad coalitions stand
lucy let's go to the times um and uh
angela rainer deputy leader of the
labour party pictured there um
no
real
apologies in sight
no she has stood firm today despite
being rebuked by sakir stama the labour
leader he's made it clear that uh her
remarks last night to the first day of
labor conference where she
referred to senior conservatives as scum
uh he made it clear that that is not
language that he would have used and
that he would be having a word with her
some of his other uh front bunch
colleagues went further lucy powell the
shadow housing secretary made clear she
thought that angela rainer had
overstepped the mark and should make
clear that she had caused a defense and
regretted that
but angel reina herself
used the rao and the conversation
provoked over this to draw attention to
some of the controversial things the
prime ministers said she said that she'd
apologize for calling the conservatives
scum when he apologized and for making
remarks that she characterized as being
homophobic racist and misogynistic so
all in all it's been a lot of
recriminations held between both parties
but
i think on both sides there have been
labour front ventures and certainly
members of the conservative government
who think that this sort of language is
not conducive to a respectful liberty
lucy thank you we have run out of time